Так виглядав Копенгаген 2 липня 2011 року.
Після катастрофічних злив вулицями данської столиці
плавали мертві щури.
Працівники сміттєзбірника потруїлися від випарів.
А один навіть помер від зараження крові.
За останні 6 років такі потужні зливи траплялися у Копенгагені чотири рази.
Стічна каналізація не справлялася з такими обсягами води.
Подібні зливи стаються і в інших великих містах.
Урбаністи шукають розв'язання проблеми.
Копенгаген знаходиться попереду міст, які трансформуються.
Адже зміна клімату робить опади дедалі більш непередбачуваними
та інтенсивними.
Деякі протиповеневі концепції передбачають
затоплення спортивних майданчиків.
Їдемо у серце Копенгагена, аби дізнатися:
Як захистити таке місто від повеней?
Ще п'ять років тому цього дерева тут не було - замість нього тут стояв би,
імовірно, якийсь позашляховик у заторі.
Цю площу перепланували. Колись тут була жвава кільцева розв'язка.
Тепер - це ліс посеред міста.
Це частина концепції перетворити Копенгаген
на свого роду гігантську "губку" після руйнівної повені 2011 року.
Політики хотіли, щоб воду можна було дуже швидко відвести з міста
- якимось розумним способом. Чи можна було б розширити каналізацію
або перебудувати її геть інакше?
Чи можна було б поєднати це з прагненням міста стати більш зеленим,
з більшим біорозмаїттям і більшою кількість місць,
де люди могли б зустрічатися?
Команда Расмуссена перетворила це кільцеве перехрестя
на невидимий захист від повеней.
Це маленький ставок, в якому ми можемо зберігати дощову воду.
Якщо випадає більше дощів, то ми маємо тут через дорогу ще більше
таких ставків, які зрештою поєднані з морем.
Ці невеликі з'єднані між собою ставки розташовані по всьому місту
для накопичення надлишків дощової води.
Є також інші концепції для зберігання води - наприклад, озеленені дахи.
Або такі сучасні стоки в районах з високим ризиком затоплення.
Все це позначено на карті, яка показує, де саме місто
може бути затоплене під час потужних злив.
Значна частина інвестицій вартістю приблизно 2 мільярди євро
розташована на глибині 20 метрів під землею.
Це основа протиповеневої концепції данської столиці - тунель.
З такою щільною міською територією ви не можете розв'язати проблему
просто екологічними рішеннями.
Джес Клаусон-Каас працює над величезним проєктом тунелю
для міської служби водопостачання.
Ви можете робити все можливе на поверхні - так можна відводити
легкий дощ. Але коли він справді ллє як з відра, необхідна велика система.
Немає способу вивести воду в гавань, не побудувавши такий тунель.
Тунель має 3 метри в діаметрі і тягнеться через місто на 18 кілометрів,
скеровуючи дощову воду в порт.
Але у нього є й інша функція: вода може зберігатися тут,
а не в каналізаційній системі, і повільно виводитися в гавань.
Це стабілізує рівень і якість води.
Під час нового шторму тунелі знову заповнюються.
Якщо станеться сильний шторм, який затопить вулиці,
ми просто відкриємо тунель і зможемо перекачати всю воду в гавань.
Вода на вулицях все одно буде. Я маю на увазі, що вони не будуть геть сухими.
Але це дозволить нам опустити рівень води з пів метра або метра
до 10 - максимум 20 сантиметрів.
І скільки води може витримати ця система?
Кількість води, яку можна транспортувати, визначає насосна станція.
А насос здатен перекачати 20 тисяч літрів на секунду.
Як тільки надходить штормовий сигнал і вода починає стікати вулицями,
насосна станція запускається і відкачує воду.
Їдемо до старого парку в центрі міста, тут є й озеленені території,
і заасфальтовані. Парк складається з трьох рівнів.
На першому - розарій, під яким зберігається вода.
Цей резервуар також служить резервом води для парку в посушливі періоди.
Коли цей резервуар буде заповнений, ми почнемо заповнювати
спортивний майданчик, який ви бачите там.
Ця водойма глибша за решту території парку,
тому вода автоматично збирається тут.
Коли резервуар заповниться, він виглядатиме так.
А ще є протиповенева стіна.
Коли йде злива, тут підіймається стіна, і ця територія позаду мене
перетворюється на величезний басейн, який накопичує стічні води.
Та чи здатні ці заходи впоратися з найгіршим сценарієм?
Завжди може налетіти ще потужніший шторм, ніж будь-який раніше.
Це може статися. До того ж зміна клімату продовжуватиметься.
Завжди можуть випасти опади, які будуть ще сильнішими.
Від цього ніхто не захищений на 100%. Але певний захист є.
Інвестиції у захист проти повеней порівнюються з ризиками
від потенційних збитків.
І це той рівень інвестицій, які ми готові робити.
Інші міста, безумовно, дуже уважно спостерігають за Копенгагеном,
оцінюючи, скільки коштуватиме інвестувати нині,
щоб зменшити шкоду від зміни клімату в майбутньому.